Let's do a little
warm-up now before moving
to the central topic
of today's lecture
on how to apply these transition
probabilities in order
to calculate some
more interesting path
behaviors of Markov chains.
So suppose that you are given
the following Markov chain,
and you are asked to calculate
the probability that starting
in state 1, you go successively
to state 2, then state 6,
and then 7.
So this is really what
we are asked here.
You start at 1, then
you go to 2, 6, and 7.
So how to calculate
such a probability?
Well, we can use a version
of the multiplicative rule
we have introduced before.
And so what is the specific
format of that rule
that I'm going to use here?
You have three events like that,
B, C, D. They are conditioned
on A. And I will say that this
is the probability of B given
A, times the probability of
C given A intersection B,
times the probability of D given
A intersection B intersection
C. So this is a version of
the multiplicative rule.
And this is what we're going
to use here, so let's do it.
This is going to be
equals to the probability
that X1 equals 2 given X0
equals 1, times the probability
that X2 equals 6
given X0 equals 1,
and X1 equals 2
times the probability
that X3 equals 7 times
X0 equals 1, X1 equals 2,
and then X2 equals 6.
So multiplication rule.
Now here, this is p12.
And here, we are using
the Markov property.
What it says here is,
what is the probability
that I will be in state 6, given
that I was in 1 and then 2.
And we know that having
the entire trajectory
doesn't matter, it's
just the last step.
So it's essentially
times, this one is p26.
And for the same reason, this
one is nothing else than p67.
The important message
here is that to find
the probability of a specific
trajectory like this one,
you just need to multiply
the transition probabilities
that you find along
the trajectory.
So this is what we have here.
Now suppose that you want
to find the probability
that in four times
steps, you find yourself
in a specific
state say, 7, given
that you started in a
specific initial state say, 2.
This is really
what we want here.
You're here, and then you
end up here after four steps.
So how do you calculate that?
Well, one way is to use our
recurrence formula for rij
that we have described before.
Another, for small
examples like this one,
when the number of times
steps in the future
is small-- in that
case four-- one
can perhaps use a brute
force calculation.
So what is a brute
force calculation?
Well, you try to enumerate
all possible trajectories,
and then you sum all
their probabilities.
So in that case, I think
we have three trajectories,
but I'm not so sure, so
let's try to enumerate them.
So you start here,
and one possibility
in a one-step transition
is to go to 6.
Then from 6 you go to 7,
then from 7 you go back to 6.
And then from 6 you
again go to 7, all right?
So that, if we look and use
the rule that we have developed
before, it would
be the probability
of going to 6 times p67
times p76 and times p67.
So this is one way of doing it.
What would be another path?
Well, from 2,
instead of going to 6
you could go to 1
in one transition.
Then you go back to 2, then
we go to 6, and then right up
to 7.
So essentially here, what
we have is plus p21 times
p12 times p26 times p67.
And what is the
third way to do that?
So there is a third path.
You're starting from here, yes?
You go here in one step.
Here you do a jump on
itself, and another jump,
and then you go to 7.
So in that case, you would
have plus p26 times p66 times
p66 times p67.
So here we have the entire
solution, all right?
So this is what is
called, by brute force.
Now of course, if
instead of 4, here,
you had something like 200,
the number of trajectories
would grow exponentially
with this number of steps.
And this is not
practical anymore.
Using the recursion
formula would
have been a much
better approach.
And in some sense would have
a much better complexity.
Essentially, a linear
growth as a function of time
steps in the future.
More precisely, for a chain
with a state space of m,
at each time steps you need
to update all our rij's.
So for each pair of
ij, so each of these
would take about m squared.
And so the total
computational complexity
would grow about n times m
squared as a function of n.